Donald Trump reset his tough stance on
immigration last night going back to
where he started the Republican
presidential nominee declared he will
enforce all immigration laws and build a
wall along the border with Mexico the
hardline speech followed a much more
subdued meeting with Mexico's president
earlier in the day Trump praised
Mexico's cooperation but the two men had
different stories about the wall in
question and specifically who will pay
for it major Garrett is in Phoenix where
he covered Trump's immigration speech
last night major good morning to you
good morning to Donald Trump's on
display yesterday the polite deferential
diplomat in Mexico City and then hours
later here in Phoenix the hot-tempered
uncompromising advocate of border walls
and mass deportation the Trump
supporters have come to love and in this
context demand in the process of
delivering his speech Trump ended a
brief public flirtation with a softer
immigration policy
anyone who has entered the United States
illegally his subject to deportation in
Phoenix Donald Trump promised mass
deportations but did not explain how he
would do it people will know that you
can't just smuggle in hunker down and
wait to be legalized undocumented
immigrants must return to their home
country and apply for reentry Trump said
vowing to subject new immigrants to
ideological tests it's our right as a
sovereign nation to choose immigrants
that we think are the likeliest to
thrive and flourish and love us
Trump's 10-point plan included tripling
the number of immigration agents to
round up undocumented criminals
withholding federal tax dollars from
sanctuary cities and a biometric
registry to halt visa overstays you
ready Trump's number one point was his
most rehearsed we will build a great
wall along the southern border and
Mexico will pay for the wall know it yet
but they're gonna pay for the work this
time though Trump added a new diplomatic
wrinkle
Mexico will work with us I absolutely
believe it and especially after meeting
with their wonderful wonderful president
in Mexico City Trump met with president
Enrique Pena Nieto and traded campaign
bombast for the hushed tones of
cooperation we all share a common
interest in keeping our hemisphere safe
Trump misled reporters however by saying
Mexican financing of a border wall did
not come up we did discuss the wall we
didn't discuss payment of the wall
that'll be for a later date
in fact the topic did come up Pena Nieto
said afterward he told top Trump
directly at the beginning of the meeting
Mexico would never pay for the wall
Trump aids later grudgingly admitted
differences of opinion something DeMarco
Trump simply did not want to recognize
in front of the Mexican president all
right major thank you